Allah shadow.
Muhamad.
[Silence]
Hos
Allahbar.
[Silence]
All
alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. Foreham
[Silence]
Subhanahu
Wasam. forch.
[Silence]
My dear brothers, respected elders,
beloved youth, brothers and sisters, we
thank Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for
keeping us alive one more day on the
path of Islam on theatim and allowing me
and you to enter his house on this
blessed month of Ramadan and allowing
him to worship him in the manner that
pleases him. We ask Allah subhanaa tala
except from us the we do in his path. A
mean and I bear witness there's no deity
worthy of worship except for Allah
subhana tala and prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is his last
and final messenger. For surely who
Allah subhana ta choose to guide us
again misguide and he choose to misguide
us and guide him back to the path and we
seek refuge in Allah from darkness of
for ourselves and evil of our deeds for
Allah is all knowing and allseeing what
his creation does. All praise is due to
Allah the knowing the aware. He guided
us to Islam and taught us the Quran and
made us from the ummah of fasting and
night prayers. We praise him for his
bountiful giving. We are grateful his
beneficence. His prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam would stand in the prayer at
night worshiping him reciting the verses
of the Quran until his honorable feet
would swell. So be conscious of Allah
subhanaa tala and obey him and take heed
from what has passed from the Ramadan
for what and for what remains of it for
the record of deeds have closed for the
past days from what they contain of good
or bad deeds. So congratulations to
those who have excelled in condolences
to those who have fell short. Allah
subhana t says in the Quran
and so whoever does good equal to the
weight of an
Adam or a small ant shall see it and
whoever does evil equal to the weight of
an Adam or a small ant shall see it. The
blessed month of Ramadan is a month of
fasting, charity, generosity and night
prayers. And it is likewise the month of
Quran and criterion between right and
wrong. Allah subhana t has mentioned and
soak the month of Ramadan is which was
reve in which was revealed the Quran a
guidance to mankind and a clear proof
for the guidance and the criterians
between right and wrong. And Allah
says, "And indeed we sent the Quran down
in the night of decree." And Allah
says, "And indeed we sent it down during
a blessed night. Indeed, we were to warn
the mankind as mentioned in surah dan.
Allah revealed the Quran a light whose
illumination does not turn off. A lamp
whose fire is not extinguished. A way
that those following it do not go
astray. A might that those supporting
are not defeated. For the material of
eman faith and fountain of knowledge,
and a sea that is not depleted by those
who draw from it, an infinite infinite
spring for those who take from it. Allah
made it a quencher for the thirst of
scholars and a spring for the hearts of
jurists. A medicine after which there is
no disease. It is Allah's firm rope and
the wise reminder and a straight path.
It has narratives be for those of those
before us and the news of those who will
come after them and a judge between the
people. It is a truth and not an
amusement.
And with the truth he sent it, and with
the truth it descended, whoever acts
upon it, it is
rewarded. And whoever jud judge judges
by it, it is just. And whoever calls it
to guide to the straight path. And
whoever asks guidance from it, Allah
will honor him. And whoever seeks
guidance from it other than Allah will
disgrace them. Through it Allah raises
people and lowers other and it will come
as an intercessor for the people on the
day of judgment
asam mentioned in the hadith mentioned
in
mentioned in narration
iniam the blessed of the creations said
whoever recites a letter from the book
of Allah subhana tala he will receive
the reward from
it and each good deed is a
multiplier of 10
rewards of it and I do not tell you
al if lamb me is a word but I tell to
you al if is a word lamb is a word and a
meme is a word a person without the
Quran is a life without water and
air rather he ills with his senses
within himself this is because Quran is
the medicine and the cure as Allah
subhana ta mentioned
Indeed, we send down the Quran that
which is healing and mercy for the
believers, but it does not increase the
wrongdoers except in
loss. I'm reminded often at times of the
beautiful
verses
of when he said in his beautiful poetry,
Indeed, they were blessed. Allah gave
them honor in the world just because
they were
Muslims. And we have lost that honor and
in our darknesses today because we have
left the Quran and went astray.
Many Muslims recite the
Quran. Peace and tranquility fill their
hearts and limbs. Then the souls
advances not minding what happens to it
while it reads it when when the read the
words of his lord. It
says and never will be struck except for
what Allah has decreed upon us. He's our
protector upon Allah. Let upon let Allah
let their believers
rely. Indeed, every single word of Quran
is true.
Today we fear that if people get to know
that we are Muslims, something will
happen to us. And Allah reminds us in
the Quran over and over again that is
not the
case. You see, I recited those couplets
for you, but we truly have to dissect
that and understand what Abbal was
saying.
And I'll read you the passage of the
Quran that I think would come closest to
what was trying to say.
So it
mentions to those people to whom the
hypocrites said indeed people have
gathered against you so fear
them but merely it increases their faith
and they
said sufficient is Allah for
us. And then Allahh mentions in the
following couple of
verses. And that's what a Shan
does. He leads people astray. He makes
them fear.
If I take 15 minute break from my work
to go for my Zohar prayer or for my
prayer or I go pray then people will
look at me
weirdly or I will be judged for a Muslim
that I
am. But Allah is reminding
us this is what the devil does. He comes
to those who are people of
belief. Why would he go to a
disbeliever? Why would a shaitan go to a
disbeliever? There's nothing to do for
him
there. So he comes and plays with the
person who
believes. A person who disbelieves is
already out of his his
his control. He doesn't you know what
what more can you do to him?
So he comes and plays and toys with the
emotions of the
believers and he tells
them be careful be fearful what will
happen. Allah
says and fear mean if you are truly a
believer.
How many people are unjust to the Quran
and shun giving its
due? And how few are those who are
knowledgeable of the Quran? And if one
goes searching for the genuinely acting
upon it based on most of what is seen
and heard, he will come up
empty-handed. Verily, people have
deserted the Quran and they replaced the
superior with the inferior, idally
wasting their time away through day and
night.
And as a perfect example of it is that
we find time to scroll through our
social
medias, through our Facebooks and
Instagrams and check for food recipes in
the month of Ramadan. But unfortunately,
we do not have time to read a page of
Quran. Every night onar, we want to have
something
different, something more tantalizing
and engaging, sweet and savory.
And we spend hours upon
hours to find ingredients for it to
refine our
recipes and we don't find time for the
Quran. May Allah guide us
all. Allah completed the line of
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam granting him eminence.
He almighty sealed the reveal. He sealed
the and revealed the books with the
noble sealed the books and revealed the
noble Quran. The book of Allah his
speech revealed not
created. I'm going to repeat
that Quran is Allah's speech which is
revealed not created free from every
imperfection divide our defects and
protect it from contradiction within it.
As Allah subhana t mentions in the Quran
within it when within it is guidance
illumination and
healing
says which
are and meaning of those are only known
to Allah subhana wa
tala we do not have the capability nor
the insight to dive into it to see what
it
means and there are and there are
scholars who have said this means that
and that and to be truthful with you to
be honest with you only Allah subhanaa t
knows what they
mean the book which is revealed to you
[Arabic recitation]
that you might bring mankind out of
darkness into the light by the
permission of their lord to the path of
exalted in might and praiseworthy
My brothers and sisters, respected
elders, I can stand here all day and
quote a verse from the Quran after the
after another verse and after another
verse and after another verse and time
will end and I will pass and my sound
will finish. But Allah's Quran's words
will never finish. And that's the truth
of it.
I want to conclude the first sermon at
least by bringing an attention to what
Allah subhana tala has
mentioned or what's nar what is narrated
in the in the in the
hadith
mentioned that he said he heard the
messenger
ofah
say best of Who the men the amongst the
best of you are those who learn the
Quran and teach it. I want to draw your
attention to the hadith. Look at the the
precise manner which Allah sallallahu
alaihi wasallam spoke and as we know
from the Quran Allahh says that nothing
comes out of the mouth of the messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam except it is
by the of Allah.
Everything he speaks is inspired by
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. So pay
attention what he
says. Best of you are amongst you are
the ones who learn the Quran. Learning
of the Quran comes first besides
teaching the Quran.
And to be honest with you, learning is
an act that is starts from inception of
a man and ends at the death of the man.
For those who believe that we've learned
everything and we know everything, they
are indeed wrong. We ask Allah subhana
wa ta'ala to bless us with the Quran in
this month to read it day and night to
read it on our sides and when laying
down. We ask Allah subhana t to
enlighten our hearts with the Quran and
make our speech according to the Quran
and make our acts according to the Quran
and clean our hearts with the Quran and
cure our illnesses with the Quran and
unite us as an ofasam with the Quran
and may Allah make the Quran an
intercess inter interceding for us on
the day of and make us make it upon us
as a witness that this man this person
has read
me. Please move forward.
[Silence]
brothers, if you can move forward. If
there's a space in front of you, please
take that space and move forward.
I want to sh I share I I I I I kept the
first hudbarly short because I want to
share a hadith with you of sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. Probably one of the
most amazing a hadith that at least for
me that I have come across that shows
the beauty and the respect that
sallallahu alaihi wasallam gave to the
Quran.
mentioned on the authority
of they came to one day and they asked
to tell them a story that was the most
interesting
about so she said I will she thought
about it for a bit and she said I'll
tell you a story that I find the most
interesting from the life
of some. And let me go back a little
bit. Sorry, I skipped
a said to
Can you excuse me so I can worship my
Allah subhana
t and that's a that's a that's a hint
for us as married
men that wasallam is asking his wife for
permission to do extra in night because
your wife has hook upon you as
well that's a separate inshallah there's
a lot more stuff to cover on that
inshallah
And she replies to
him. She says, "I swear to Allah subh, I
love your company and your
closeness." And then he stand, she says,
he stood
up and then he stood up and he started
praying.
He says, "As he prayed, his eyes started
to water. He started
crying. And he cried so much that his
cheeks became
wet. And he cried so much after that
that his beard became wet. And
eventually he cried so much the tears
from his beard actually were wetting the
floor that he was standing
upon. So Bal came and it was time for
salah.
I don't know if you guys know this or
not, but
when used to
make every time he
said, he would look at the blessed face
[Silence]
of so said, why are you crying so much?
Allah has forgiven all of your previous
and your your coming sins. There's
nothing upon
you. He said, "Do not should I not be a
thankful
person? Should I not be a thankful
person for Allah subhana wa ta'ala?
Tonight Allah has revealed a verse upon
me that whoever reads it should be in
this
state. And I guarantee you most of has
read this ayah and have gone by it and
never paid attention to
it. It's an ayah from
Such a beautiful
life. And I always say this as a Muslim,
if you do not walk outside in the nature
and find signs of Allah subhana tala,
you're doing something
wrong. You're doing something extremely
wrong in your life.
We need to change our
perspective. All of this creation around
us
gives only one witness that there's only
one Allah subhana wa tala.
That's it cannot be more than one
Allah. I finish with this.
When I used
to do with with Christians, I used to do
comparative
religion, comparative religion with
them, I was always asked, what happens,
Hassan, if you die and you get across
either side and Allah says you screwed
up. Valid question to be asked. And I
said, "That's fine because on the day of
judgment, if I stood in front of my
Allah and he told me there was more than
one God, I will tell him he was
wrong." Because the unism in the world
only gives witness to one
God. The creation, the beauty, the
elegance, the precise
mathematics, the position of everything
only says there's only one God.
We could not cook a pot of food when
there's three chefs in the
kitchen. How can this beautiful world be
created if there was more than one
God? And that's my answer. I could be
wrong. But indeed, there is only one
God. And we need to connect with him in
the most sincerest form. And we need to
come back to Allah subhana wa ta'ala. I
remind you and myself to take heed. The
time is not a lot. This month flew
by. We literally have less
than a week left behind
us. So let's connect with
Allahha. Mix and sinca to Allah subhana
tala. Ask him for forgiveness of our
being
unmindful and ask for forgiveness for
our brothers and sisters. And I remind
you and myself not to forget our
brothers and sisters first and foremost
who are fighting in
hazine and in Sudan and in Burma and in
China and in Kashmir and in H and
everywhere they are fighting. May Allah
subh bring them victory. Grant them
justice and aid them through the armies
that we do not see. But Allahh knows of
[Silence]
them.
for inch.
[Silence]
Allah.
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
Still your lines fill the gaps in
between. May Allah subh mercy upon us.
Allah. Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
Amen. forbal.
[Silence]
Allah Allahb.
Allahbar. Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Amen.
All right.
[Silence]
him.
Love me.
[Silence]
Love, Lord.
Allah. ,
[Silence]
My dear brothers and sisters, Asalamu
alaykum. As always, I'm requesting 5
minutes of your time as a donation for
the sake of Allah tala and you will be
rewarded generously. So, please bear
with us today. Very important cause for
raising funds. It is for the charity.
The people who are in need, we want to
provide help them provide some some
donations and inshallah we will be able
to you know raise the level of our
community. inshallah
prosper. There is one reminder from the
hadith I want to just mention that the
believers shade on the day of judgment
will be the their charity and that's
very important to realize and understand
that that is something that is so
precious. will be really thankful to
Allahhaala for allowing us to make the
donations now in our lifetime while we
are able to do so. So without any
further delay, I would to ask who
wants to raise the hand for $10,000.